مرحباً يا رفاق ، نائب الرئيس كامالا هاريس
في وضع التحكم في الضرر بعد هذا
التبادل مع الطالب الجامعي في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع ، كانت هناك أموال
مخصصة لمواصلة دعم إسرائيل
وهو ما يؤلمني لأنها
إبادة عرقية وتشريد
للناس وأعتقد أن هذا أمر
رائع.  لقد تحدث الناس كثيرًا في
ما يحتاجون إليه وأشعر أن
هناك نقصًا في الاستماع
وأشعر أنني بحاجة إلى
الرد على رد فعل سعيد جزئياً
، ومرة أخرى يتعلق هذ
بحقيقة أن صوتك هو وج
ة نظرك تجربتك ال
قيقة  لا ينبغي
قمعها ويجب سماع النقطة
التي تثيرها حول السياسة التي تتعلق
بالسياسة الخارجية للشرق الأوسط ،
لا يزال لدينا
نقاشات صحية في بلدنا حول
ما هو الطريق الصحيح ولا
ينبغي قمع صوت أي شخص بشأن تلك
المطبوعات الإسرائيلية التي قفزت  على هاريس
لعدم رده على
توصيف الطلاب
لأفعال إسرائيل تجاه الفلسطينيين بأنها
إبادة عرقية و  تقول المصادر إن مكالمات CNN وصلت
إلى البيت الأبيض من عدة
منظمات يهودية رائدة تعبر
عن مخاوفها
من أن مكتب نائب الرئيس
يسعى الآن لتقليل
التداعيات بإصدار بيان اليوم يقول إن
نائب الرئيس لا يتفق بشدة مع
توصيف الطالب لإسرائيل
بأنه طالب  التي عبرت عن
رأيها الشخصي خلال حصة في
العلوم السياسية مؤكدة أن نائبة
الرئيس التي زوجها يهودي
كانت ثابتة في التزامها
بإسرائيل ، هذا الغبار هو مجرد واحد في
سلسلة لنائب الرئيس في الأشهر التسعة التي قضاها
في الوظيفة ، حيث يتعين على الجناح الغربي أن  رفض علنًا
تقارير الاقتتال الداخلي
والخلل الوظيفي في مكتب نائب الرئيس
في يونيو ، وقد
طغت عليها انتقادات
تسليمها الفظ لرسالة إدارة بايدن
إلى المهاجرين
الغواتيماليين.  تلك الرحلة الخطيرة
إلى حدود الولايات المتحدة المكسيكية
تفعل  لا تأت
لا تأتي هذه الإجابة تثير الكثير من الأشخاص
بما في ذلك أعضاء من حزبها ،
وتستدعي التشكيك في قطعها الدبلوماسية
بعد يوم واحد فقط ، وتسبب هاريس في
عناوين الأخبار مرة أخرى من خلال رفض
الانتقادات التي مفادها أنها لم تصل
أبدًا إلى الحدود التي ذهبنا إليها.
لم أذهب إلى الحدود
ولم أذهب إلى أوروبا وأعني
أنني لا أفهم النقطة
التي تثيرها وتتسبب في احتكاك
مع عضو رئيسي في حزبها
لا يمكننا الاستمرار  بهذه الطريقة للذهاب إلى
غرب فرجينيا والجلوس لإجراء
مقابلات محلية حول خطة تحفيز
كوفيد دون إعطاء تنبيه إلى
سيناتور الولاية منذ فترة طويلة جو مانشين ، لم
أصدق أنه لم يتصل بي أحد ،
سنحاول إيجاد مسار للحزبين
لذلك أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى ذلك ، لكننا بحاجة إلى
العمل معًا ، فهذه ليست طريقة
للعمل معًا ما تم إنجازه